hey guys how's it going so today we're
here hanging out LA live at the
Microsoft Theatre because tomorrow is
the game award so I'm really excited
it's gonna be so much fun in Francesca's
here so we were filming some things I'm
not even sure I might want to say what
I'm doing
does anybody know I am okay this is
great I'm always so afraid to say
anything
there were filming some really cool
stuff from battlefront for Star Wars and
I'm pretty excited because we've got
some the EA game changers are here I'll
introduce you to them here in a second
you guys probably know them if you watch
twitch or if you're on youtube we'd be
having fun machetes and stuff and I hope
you guys watch the game Awards tomorrow
I'm so excited because they've got some
amazing like music remixes I don't know
what is he's playing today yeah I read
it on Twitter oh yes churches yes I like
Georgia and also the after party scrilla
it's gonna be so much fun I'm excited
can we ice skate here it looks a little
bit like a swimming pool currently they
have it last year yes I just want to be
a big penguin right now and just do that
you can do it it would be a great video
I'll send it to you I'm son to the clip
table here hello hello hello hello
everybody does that make a bomb
hi we're here for the shows and then we
have to be at the Microsoft theater many
of you guys remember this is actually oh
it's oh I was so confused so this is the
AMD greenroom oh my gosh hello oh we've
been having a really fun day pretty
excited tomorrow this is we're going to
be hanging out doing the live stream
we're gonna be chatting we don't
actually hundred-percent know what we're
doing yet it's a big mystery is just
shrouded mystery it is we like mystery
I'm gonna tell you I've learned a lot
about a lot of things about you can't be
around me because I can look at you I
can't even we're sitting there like I
can't even look you in the eye I can't
even like look near you I could not even
look to my left they even gave her
Direction really all right you need to
look at him to start this off I'm go to
second shoot I can't do they go okay
nevermind don't look at him when you
drive it off to you not make eye contact
see I'm excited you guys should
definitely watch tomorrow tweet us I'm
losing my voice I'm just getting over a
cold and it's actually a three week cold
so I don't know that's a minute it was
terrible that's the man's legit man yeah
this is the first day that I feel normal
are you are you vlogging away to what
great
the IG exclusive here with mr. Jeff
Keely how are you doing Stan yeah I'm
ready for a big show tomorrow and you
were gonna be a big part of it right I'm
so excited
guys look at the stage pretty cool Jeff
you slept I slept a little bit last
night tonight I'm not sleeping that so
what can we expect the game works oh
well we can expect you in the green room
Battlefront green room which is gonna be
pretty cool we've got her saying he's
doing that really cool pretty amazing
medley of a bunch of videogame themes
and he loves you got churches coming up
who are gonna perform oh that's a song
there we've got a lot of really cool
games are gonna be showing off world
premieres of big games coming up next
year because I don't farcry we're doing
I love I'm so excited
far cry is pretty great so we're doing
that we're doing in the show we've got
some cool stuff for The Walking Dead if
people are fan of The Walking Dead
yes exactly another Walking Dead here we
got we got Kiefer Sutherland's coming
which would be cool be doing oh he's
probably gonna tell us I can't tell you
okay stay tuned but he'll be here
Shaquille O'Neal Shaq will be here
really he's gonna talk about your Shaq
food everywhere Liam Shaq Shaq foo
before your time he might maybe yes so
an old game for like 20 years ago Shaq
did and everyone's wanted him to do
another one there may be another shot
for coming well everybody who's excited
about that Shaq fit into your green room
I don't think so I don't know the
ceilings are a little bit less you want
to see Shaq playing a video game with
his hands especially like a PlayStation
these are the questions we need to ask
track tomorrow I will and then Mark
Hamill is coming really yeah I'm going
to be here yes Luke Skywalker will be
here you think Luke is gonna come to
your Star Wars room I hope so because I
once got a selfie with him and it was a
worse selfie ever so really I had read
it I need to read it hopefully Luke
maybe maybe r2d2 Sirte
Oh cry fangirl could be alright in your
room have you seen any any Threepio r2d2
anyone
no no we've just got the game just a ton
of battlefront today's was really fun
well the stage works so awesome the real
question is how does everybody watch
tomorrow you guys can watch it online
for free on basically any platform out
there YouTube twitch Xbox Live and also
go 90 which is a new app for iOS and
Android they will have it live I know
you've got a channel I just got my
volume
Jeff was my first follower so if you
guys don't have an ID check it out alive
across all these screens see Justine and
me live at the game Forge and lots of
other really cool people so we'll see
you later
bye yeah oh oh you guys know that we
started doing this last night and we did
it and he's brilliant he's so smart
smart dog